[Music]
what's not by General Hospital you I
mean I mean I'm sorry let's talk about
General Hospital my opinion one of the
best of the soaps ever yeah
now it's transitioning to Children's
Hospital hospital now back to Children's
Hospital you're on the quick way by the
way I though super much it's what I do
you I'm curious you were on the cast but
now you're directing episodes as well
and I'm I've always wondered how do you
get the respect of the crew that's a
pretty irreverent yeah gang that you
have there and I would think now you
have to direct them they're not gonna
take you seriously there any of your
hard time it's hard yeah they're like a
bunch of monkeys these people we really
are crazy I'm one of them normally on
the other side but in order to kind of
command sort of respect for something
yeah um I adopted this jumpsuit the sort
of sweat jumpsuit never been out of this
country let's say I am right now
let me tell you something I am American
and you can tell from that photo not
really no you can
you could be mocking America no you're
actually right so what's the bandana all
about um well that's also for a sense of
power as well because it's like it's
Allah Axl Rose oh you're you're an Axl
Rose fan
oh who me yeah yeah do you know you the
one I'm talking about yes no those
people in a rowboat out at sea GNR I am
a GNR fan we said GNR when you're like
really close tight but you don't yeah
you're I don't know Guns and Roses so
don't need to say you don't have to go
Gian are you know try to try it it's
nice I just did I didn't like all right
so Guns N'Roses the GNR Guns and Roses
fan a love acts all right and actually
for my 30th birthday I made all my
friends sort of dress up we did like a
fancy dress kind of party and I made
everyone dress up as if it was like 1997
you know like a concert for for Guns and
Roses cuz I never got to go to that cuz
I mean I was given tattoos but I wasn't
allowed to go to GNR cops yeah it seems
like you could have gone yeah you were
doing all kinds of stuff but okay so I
think with a picture of this well this
is us here they will say that you know
all the November rain video I was
Stephanie Seymour that's near 70 and who
was playing it so Cameron Diaz Cameron
Diaz's is Axl was Axl I was like
I want to sleep with that solos she ya
know everyone went all out for it I was
very impressed
well make sure I mentioned this this is
very funny show Children's Hospital
Arizona midnight on Thursdays on Adult
Swim General Hospital no idea no clear
anymore I don't know I'm just worried
about Luke and Laura yes if you get that
reference
[Applause]
man you reach back for that thirty years
ago I think I don't know